alexandria ocasio-cortez and the squad
have a new idea to make their agenda
happen they're now pushing biden to
bypass congress and use the power of the
pen on a list of 55 policies including
banning new fossil fuel leases declaring
a national climate emergency and
canceling student loan debt the
progressive caucus tweeting to the
president to quote be guided by racial
gender and economic justice to get their
agenda done and tammy i'll begin with
you because uh
additionally well
just a second because additionally the
congressional black and hispanic
caucuses are also expected to issue
their wish slash demand lists um in the
coming weeks and really the message here
seems to be look we helped get you to
the oval office it's time for for you to
take care of some of our items tammy
yeah well all they need to do is look at
the polls right americans are very upset
that's an understatement uh no one
elected alexandria ocasio-cortez to be
president as a matter of fact joe biden
was elected president because he said he
was a moderate he they said he was he
was back to life is normal and lord
knows they're kind of giving that to us
but it they they have to recognize that
and yet you have to give them credit in
the face of everything they will not
stop they're like the angriest dog in
the world right they're pulling on that
chain and they want what they want but
this is the problem is that it's not
based in reality it's not based on
what's best for this country and it's
dangerous my goodness what more do they
need to see to recognize that the
american people don't want what they're
selling we are rejecting what they're
selling and yet they do not care this
should be a lesson for all of us about
what is driving these particular
individuals all of their plans and the
part that's been implemented like the
war on fossil fuels has in part led us
to this point which is inspiring the
enemies that we have around the world
well and tammy you're right i mean aoc
is not the president however on
instagram she did channel him recently
take a listen
tell you a secret
most people don't really know what
capitalism is
most people don't even know what
socialism is
but most people are not capitalists
because they don't have capitalist money
they're not billionaires
oh my god
charlie
oof
that was terrifying i'm gonna have
nightmares
i'm sorry i'm sorry i won't do it again
please no it's amazing though i and you
know um it's sort of hard to determine
whether they're they're this dumb or
they're evil because as tammy pointed
out the reason we're in the situation
we're in is because joe biden after
claiming to be a moderate and spending a
career
positioning himself as a moderate ran
off with the circus on the green new
deal nonsense which led to exactly the
situation we're in and exactly the
situation that the ukrainian people are
in because they jacked up oil prices
gave vladimir putin enough money to
invade and weakened america to the point
that we have to turn to places like
venezuela for oil just and of course gas
prices are going through the roof and
inflation is going through the roof they
have weakened us their policies have
weakened us the only good uh thing here
is i do think that the fact that the
squad is talking about forcing biden to
to to run off with the circus again on
all the rest of their crazy policies is
proof that they know that they've seen
the polling they know they're going to
get shellacked in november and their
best chance is to try to do it all with
what did obama say with the pen and the
phone that's their only hope
well and joey as you remember
president trump's first year in office
he signed 55 executive orders slammed by
the democrats and he did do more
than president obama who in his first
year enacted 38.
president biden so far has it has
issued 77 executive orders rather he did
that in 2021
is this the way of the future just
bypass congress because they're not
getting things done and that essentially
would make the president kind of like a
king uh it's the way of the present it's
not the way of the future
obama was heavy-handed uh relay goes
back to some of the things the bush
administration did unchecked coming into
the wars and some of that warranted
maybe some of it not but this is what i
will tell you about that a
a
president trump executive order is not
the same as the president by an
executive order as a conservative i can
tell you an executive order saying hey
that crazy regulation the last guy did
i'm going to get rid of is not the same
as writing 77 executive orders that put
new rules on our lives new restrictions
on our economy and new restrictions on
our freedom and that's the problem and
that's what
that's what makes this so hard to
stomach
to see that you know not only what
president biden has already done to go
from this middle of the road joe to
radical joe but the idea that he could
succumb to pressure from someone who can
send a tweet and raise a million dollars
which is aoc strength listen this is
self-preservation for the squad they're
they're wrangling votes and money like
they always do by telling people that
they are victims to their born status um
that's not how you govern a country
though so it doesn't matter to them it's
not a big deal to them neither none of
them are up for speaker of the house
they're just securing their seat and
raising a bunch of money and that's how
they secure power in congress which
really is the true irony in all this
what makes aoc powerful not her ideas
the amount of money she can raise great
point great point hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else